welcome to cloud minute today I'm going  to show you how to create a managed  instance group from the command line  i'll be using cloud shell but you can  use your own terminal if you'd prefer  first we need to create an instance  template name your template set the  machine type and set a boot disk size  additional flags can be found in the  help if you want to see what's in a  given template use describe now you can  create a managed instance group from  your template name your group classify  the template and specify the group size  now you've created a managed instance  group using g-cloud check out our other  cloud minutes